I wonder how representative you think
the media conversation is to what
ordinary black and brown and whatever
people are sort of talking around the
dinner table it's not representative at
all would be my answer to that yeah
because I I think
the actual experiences of black people
um
are so diverse that to even use
um a term like
black Voice or the black community
does a massive disservice to those
different values those different points
of views those different experiences
so I I think and the kind kinds of
things as well that black people often
discuss the kind of values that black
people often espouse
are often counter to the kind of values
that many of these um self-appointed
um black pundits or intellectuals or
whatever you want to call them what what
they express because I think one of the
things about
um many black people in the UK
um I'm thinking in particular of many
black African communities is the extent
to which religion place a pivotal role
in how they see themselves
and the kind of cultural or social
conservatism which is implied by that is
not something that we often discuss well
they don't have pride Flags
yeah it's not something that is often
discussed because that would lead to
many awkward conversations
yeah and I think it's one thing I want
to emphasize is that London is the most
religious place in the UK and London
yeah and by the way acceptance of LGBT
it's the most conservative yes the most
conservative in that respect yeah and
it's it's because of yeah ethnic
minorities or religious differences yeah
yeah exactly exactly yeah and it's not
just um it's not just like the black or
or even or Asian Muslim it's also like
um Eastern European immigrants as well
who often tend to be quite Catholic as
well yeah in terms of the religious
background
um so that's that's why
um there is that kind of tension which
is that in in the most
Multicultural parts of the country you
also get the most
um religious
um sensibilities which are expressed
and yet at the same time they uh the the
white middle class liberal expects all
of these people to vote labor yeah and
to have deeply Progressive views but
they do though this is the question I
was going to ask you yeah why do big
cities then and it's it's not just
London obviously but why do all the big
cities and you see it here and in
America that's one of the uniting
factors is they're always consistently
left-wing yeah right yeah which is
interesting given what you're saying how
do you explain that yeah I think I think
um
I think it's it's it's it's just a kind
of political tribalism essentially
rather than any sorts of genuine
consideration of the policies
um and the values that are embodied by
any particular party
um so I think with voting preferences
it's it's often based on Vibes it's
often based on any sort of
um pre-intellectual affiliation rather
than any genuine consideration of of any
sort of of what the parties actually
stand for do you think part of it is
also as well that
you know
if you come from an ethnic minority that
automatically means that you are in the
minority yeah yeah and therefore you
were going to you do not want to stand
out as much because you don't want to be
alienated from your tribe whatever your
tribe may be by being conservative or
saying hey guys I think this commentator
is actually talking nonsense I think
that is a part of it
um but I also think there's another
striking Dimension to discussions about
diversity and politics
um so one of the interesting things
about the UK is that in the conservative
party we there are many
um prominent conservative politicians
that come from an Asian background
including our current prime minister uh
Mr Rishi sunak
um but I think one dimension to this
hasn't been spoken
enough about which is that many of these
um prominent Asian conservative
politicians
um
didn't arrive directly from Asia they
came through the roots of East Africa
and I think
um and I think it makes sense why the
families
espouse conservative points of views
because
um if if you come from
um if your family comes from an East
African country where they were
basically kicked out by the girl like
the Jews of these times they're
basically kicked out because they were
considered parasites
um if you come from that particular
background it would make sense why you
would not trust the government to solve
all the issues in society it would make
sense why you wouldn't trust the states
it would make sense why you would
emphasize the importance of family the
importance of individuals driving
individual aspiration if you come from
that particular background
um and I think it does make sense why
people like we wishes to you like and
the other prominent conservative Asian
politicians are are conservative because
of that particular
um background and I think it also makes
sense why somebody like um Cami
Butternut who's also a very prominent
conservative politician from a West
African background because even though
she was born in the UK she actually grew
up in Nigeria and when she was growing
up in Nigeria Nigeria was a military
dictatorship
so it would make sense why she's got
many positive views about the UK
yeah
foreign